today I'm BuzzFeed we're going to be
talking about snails
more specifically snail facials the
things I do for this freaking company
remember me when this is over
snails use for snail facials are the
garden snails
they're called helix aspersa we're gonna
get snails put on our face for some
reason I'm excited I guess to see what
it does to my skin yeah I'm down for
anything on the face that sounds dirtier
than I but I'm really nervous my hands
are literally sweating right now we're
gonna get licked by old snails yeah so
I'm looking forward to that we have a
bunch of old cases
are you having like a vehicle fit you
know I should tell you that insects do
not like large vibrations like the
vibrations from the first ones on this
snail recently finished having sex as
you can see its appendage it's like
penis is still out so since we have such
a fun history together you get the penis
snail great you get the snow that still
has a hard-on exactly how I thought this
would go oh my god we often also puts
nails on the deck Lata Shore the chest
because it's very healing for sunburns
and stuff like that are you a okay Jenna
okay you sure what the hell morning
believe it or not nail enzyme facials
are all the rage in Asia also
you know you would be dead in a horror
movie you know that right I feel like
they're biting me that no they're not
biting you everybody thinks that the
foot the muscle on the bottom of their
feet is kind of rough I keep missing
these ladies because we have to provide
our snails with a warm wet surface
my face feels like it just had a bunch
of sludge on it and I feel after that
how could you feel after that I wasn't
crazy about this I'm gonna cry I gotta
say my skin does feel a little refreshed
my face definitely feels tighter like
almost after you do like one of those
masks that you buy at the drugstore
you're gonna just sit with you real good
sure here what I do it again if I had
really great results no matter how weird
it is I'd probably do it again there's
butterflies in this room what's happened
maybe snap for me this is not for me